stereotypes obviously affect how we
interact with each other because we we
create narratives that may or may not be
true and then treat people based on that
narrative so of course of course it's a
problem one of the biggest criticisms I
get is that I cannot make
generalizations about entire generations
of course you can of course you can
because we are products of our own
upbringing Xand so there's a group of
people whose worldview was formed based
on the experiences they had when they
came of age in the case of Millennials
they came of age in at the millennium
room they the first generation to have
cell phones in social media ubiquitous
in their lives the baby boomers came of
age in the 60s and 70s where you have
the Vietnam War you've got Richard Nixon
a massive cynicism of authority figures
and and and a rebellion to their sort of
parents sort of just work hard sort of
and you'll do fine mentality and became
much more selfishly oriented we know
what happened in the 80s and 90s with
the rise of mass layoffs as a as a
business strategy rank and yank
shareholder supremacy this is all the
products of the 80s and 90s but we can
absolutely make generalizations and many
of them are true
you know our grandparents who may have
lived through the depression or the war
they're miserly and frugal well there's
nothing wrong with them that's because
they live through the depression on the
war so it affects who they are so we the
most important thing is instead of
criticizing someone because of their
worldview because there's a lot a lot to
criticize up and down is rather to have
is to have empathy which is to try to
understand that how one generation grew
up is different to how we grew up and to
factor that into or filter that through
the way we treat someone the every
generation has liability and has great
weaknesses and every generation has
massive advantages and this youngest
generation unlike previous generations
is way more accepting of other people
who don't look like them or sound like
them they don't care what your sexuality
or gender identity is it's just a big
issue and it's got nothing to do with
liberal a conservative or where you're
from or north or south or whatever that
stuff as a generation they're just it's
just not a big deal right they're much
better at personal branding they
understand the importance of a brand way
better than you know older generations
think brand is your logo you know and
and they're also talking about doing
things with purpose now it's very often
said that Millennials want to work for
an organization that has a sense of
purpose
every generation wants to work for an
organization with a sense of purpose
Millennials are just loud about it
older generations just suffer in silence
and I applaud them for that because what
it does is it it's it's part of the
reason that so many companies are either
are becoming Purpose Driven or
pretending to be Purpose Driven is
because of massive pressure from an
entire generation so I think empathy is
king and instead of criticizing trying
to understand and recognizing that not
only can we teach them we can also learn
both ways both ways
[Music]